this summer pasar was hit by the worst
flooding ever
at the beginning of june 2013 the
historic town
was underwater estimates put the damages
at around 200 million euros
the ashenberger hotel's rosen cafe sits
right on the bank of the danube
refurbishing it as one of 20 projects
this construction contractor is
currently working on
the restaurant owner welcomes him and
shows him what the water damage did
the banquet hall restaurant and outdoor
beer garden are ruined
the owner puts the damage at about 1.3
million euros
he shows the builder a watermark it was
two and a half meters deep in some
places
the sludge and debris have been cleared
but even things that appear unscathed
need to be replaced
has to be removed because the insulation
underneath has to go too
insulation is what absorbs the water and
bacteria and other pathogens could still
be in it so that you can't really get
rid of them
everything has to come out
his workers are taking off the plaster
all the bookings for this summer hotel
reservations and weddings
had to be cancelled
we're at a standstill and we've had no
income for three months not at all
and we still don't know if we can hire
anyone and if so for how much
that's the big problem
the construction contractor has plenty
of customers in the center of paso as
well
he checks in with one of his customers
they agree
things are progressing but slowly
imagine the window is almost covered
plastering work is only just starting
now more than two months after the water
subsided
yet for shop owners every day counts
the merchandise was your capital and
it's been destroyed
you don't even have the financial means
to repair the building
so you have to wait for help
the contractor's order books are filled
to brimming and he already had plenty to
do before the flood
his 150 employees are now doing extra
shifts
he's not even trying to find more
workers everyone is already on the job
at the same time he still has to
continue with major projects
like an extension on the children's
clinic in pasa
but he doesn't want to leave anyone in
the lurch
or because workers are still doing flood
repairs
of course there are others too thank
goodness there aren't that many of them
who say
no we set a deadline and you have to
stick to it period
things in the old town are moving
forward bit by bit
the danube rose to nearly 13 meters it's
an historic benchmark that's been
immortalized on the town hall wall
residents won't soon forget this flood
even if things in pasar appear to be
getting back to normal